[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
25 janvier parole à michel laugier le
maire de montigny le bretonneux qui a
présenté ses voeux à la population et
aux différents services de la ville il
en a profité aussi pour présenter les
projets structurants pour la commune en
2010 cette parole aussi à patrick chehab
le président du comité départemental de
handball il viendra nous expliquer
notamment les bons résultats de l'équipe
de france et nous dira si ceux ci jouent
à la hausse pour les inscriptions dans
les clubs locaux
on ouvre donc cette émission avec de la
politique et la 13e cérémonie des voeux
pour michel laugier le maire divers
droite de montigny le bretonneux s'est
adressé à ses administrés en début de
semaine et à ses homologues des autres
communes
plusieurs dossiers abordés durant la
soirée logements commerces mais aussi
politiques de santé les détails avec
michel auger au micro de wilfrid vichy
et nicolas landry président de saint
quentin en yvelines michel logis est
aussi maire de montigny le bretonneux il
vient de tenir sa cérémonie de voeux
pour 2010 est bon soir michel laugier
bonsoir vous avez préféré ne pas tenir
votre cérémonie de voeux en tant que
président de saint quentin en yvelines
mais vous avez maintenu ce moment
particulier avec vos administrés tout à
fait je pense que c'est le moment aussi
pour faire passer certains messages donc
à l'agglomération j'avais décidé d'en
faire autrement pour des raisons de
restrictions financières que je peux pas
demander à tout le monde de revoir à la
baisse leurs budgets et moi continuer
sur des voeux donc là en tant que maire
de montigny
je ne sont pas les mêmes et donc je
souhaitais bien sûr adressé aux
habitants de mon tennis ce soir pour
leur expliquer beaucoup de choses c'est
déjà tout ce que l'on a fait et surtout
tout ce qu'on va faire
il ya beaucoup de projets pour 2017 on
va pas pouvoir revenir sur tout mais
concerne on ne serait ce que le logement
montigny le bretonneux
malgré le fait que la commune et une
cinquantaine d'années aujourd'hui
continue de se développer il ya encore
d'autres logements dans l'année à venir
tout à fait il ya de beaux programmes de
logements à venir mais tout simplement
vous savez on n'a plus beaucoup de
foncier sur la ville la seule réserve
foncière et qui nous reste c'est
l'emprise de l'ex autoroutes a12 donc là
aujourd'hui on est en train de faire des
démolitions reconstructions ça on est
obligé de fermer un collège une école
nouvelle biliton le club le village est
bien souvent là on va en profiter là
aussi pour faire quelques logements
supplémentaires ont partout on peut en
faire
ça paraît normal pour le parcours
résidentiel pouvoir permettre à des
personnes d'aller d'un traitement plus
grand ou de vendre son pavillon pour
venir d'appartements et aussi permettre
bien sûr aux jeunes de pouvoir rester
sur mon tennis
hormis les différents projets également
il ya un axe particulier c'est celui de
la santé il ya un pôle médical
multidisciplinaire qui va ouvrir
il ya aussi cette cette maison de
retraite pardon cet ehpad qui va ouvrir
prochainement la santé est importante et
c'est important
en plus on a fait beaucoup pour les
jeunes pour les très jeunes de même donc
est important aussi de ne pas oublier
les personnes de vieillissante donc
c'est pour ça que en fin d'année nous
aurons donc l'inauguration de notre
époque qui sera suivie ensuite de la
mise en place aussi dur raison ce
service saas est aussi très important
et puis aujourd'hui on est très soucieux
aussi des professionnels de santé
donc c'est avec eux que l'on travaille
sur une maison qu pluridisciplinaire en
accord d'ailleurs en plus avec le
diversité puisque nous avons sur la
ville bien sûr l'ufr des sciences de la
santé et donc nous travaillons là dessus
sur un projet très beau qui on va donner
bien sur le coup d'envoi au cours de
l'année 2010 cette inauguration 2018
et puis un autre axe c'est le commerce
aussi parce qu'on l'a entendu dans la
salle il ya une attente autour de ce
centre commercial de de skywest ya
presque un ouf de soulagement dans le
public tout à fait mais vous savez
malheureusement là on est sur des
particules son recrutement privé la
puissance publique n'a pas grand chose à
faire là dedans si ce n'est accompagné
donc moi j'ai fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour dynamiser et aujourd'hui donc nous
avons l'accord pour repartir sur un
nouveau projet donc aujourd'hui le
propriétaire a toutes les cartes en main
et donc on va partir vers ce qui était
prévu au tout début il y a vingt ans
c'est à dire sans trop mais recèle
tournée vers la culture et de loisirs le
loisir 6 6 correspond aujourd'hui aussi
à notre population
quand on voit tous les projets qui sont
développés sur la ville de montigny le
bretonneux on entend beaucoup de maires
qui sont inquiets aussi avec la baisse
des dotations les restrictions les
difficultés l'obligation d'augmenter les
impôts par exemple ça ne concerne pas
monter n'y est donc pas ce que moi
depuis plusieurs années j'avais anticipé
toutes ces choses là dont on connaît une
gestion très rigoureuse depuis longtemps
nous avons fait des économies c'est à
dire chaque fois que nous avions eu des
recettes exceptionnelles
plutôt que de les investir tout de suite
ou des lettres the budget de
fonctionnement pour les a gardés donc
aujourd'hui je peux faire face pour le
financement de nouveaux projets je
rappelle aussi que dans les nouveaux
projets et bien en faisait en
équipements publics
je vais aussi construire du logement
dont je vais dégager une charge foncière
qui va me permettre de pouvoir financer
une partie de l'équipement public voilà
c'est de la saine gestion
une toute dernière question qui se
redresse un peu plus au président de la
communauté d'agglomération à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
il ya des rapports qui sont
conflictuelles aujourd'hui avec les les
communes de gauche les communes de
l'opposition pour 2017 vous appelez à ce
que se soit apaisée j'imagine comment
vous allez sortir de cette situation
donc il n'y a pas de rapports
conflictuels
aujourd'hui toutes les données
techniques leur sont proposées dont nous
répondons à toutes les questions
donc aujourd'hui pour moi il n'ya plus
de barrages il n'y a plus rien ou alors
c'est de la posture politicienne
merci michel laugier bonne année à vous
merci à l'invité nous a rejoints
désormais en plateau patrick chabot
bonsoir
patrick chef vous êtes le président du
comité départemental de handball
vous êtes donc un homme heureux puisque
on va parler avec vous du succès de
l'équipe de france de handball l'équipe
de france qui joue au jeudi soir
d'ailleurs en demi finale de son mondial
face à la slovénie
on va commencer par vous demander votre
avis en tant qu'expert du monde du
handball sur sur ce match qui se profile
après la victoire contre la suède
on n'a pas envie d'être trop optimiste
mais ça s'annonce bien quand même cette
demi finale
oui donc c'est vrai que hier c'était il
ya retard c'était particulièrement tendu
donc la suède était l'une des meilleures
équipes oui ce n'est avec la france
l'amiante le talent fait de ce tournoi
et donc la slovénie s'est pas c'est une
équipe qui est bien connue des
handballeurs français mais il faut
toujours se méfier que ce genre d'
équipes qui pratiquent le même style de
jeu d'ailleurs que les suédois donc il
va pas falloir perdre trop de balles
comme ça a été un peu le cas hier
hier soir il faut surtout pas partir
trop trop de rancoeur trop gagnant il
faut rester complètement mobilisé sa
patte le piège d'ailleurs quand on est
aujourd'hui favori comme l'équipe de
france on joue chez soi devant des
milliers de personnes
on peut dire ça y est en valais en
finale mais au contraire c'est ce qui
peut un peu à l'image de ce qui s'est
passé peut être pour l'équipe de france
de football contre la finale contre le
portugal on se voyait peut-être trop
beau trop vite et oui faut toujours être
vigilant bien concentré sur le
l'événement du moment depuis environ une
dizaine d'années l'équipe de france est
est clairement la meilleure du monde
dans son sport est ce que ça vous
impressionne cette longévité dix ans
dans un sport collectif alors pense
qu'il n'y a pas de meilleure performance
au monde clairement depuis dix ans la
france
en pareil sports collectifs
effectivement c'est jamais connu ça et
donc pourtant j'ai bien connu les
difficiles débuts en petite boule au
niveau du vendeur mondial s'est
notamment
mais là effectivement c'est le cette
culture de deux formations est très très
demandés très regardé de par les autres
pays est très étrange et c'est
principalement la formation qui fait
l'habilité aujourd'hui de la wii parce
que par exemple l'année passée nous
avons eu les quatre équipes quatre
équipes championnes du monde au niveau
des garçons les moins de 17 - 19 one va
aider l'équipe de france masculine ont
clairement l'avenir l'état sur run est
reparti pour dix ans alors on se dit
toujours qu'il va y avoir un creux de
génération bah on s'aperçoit que pour
l'instant le cros de génération on le
voit pas tant mieux est ce qu'on peut se
comparer un peu aux américains au basket
ac c'est peut-être encore une autre
planète quand même le basket c'est
vraiment une culture professionnelle
très très aboutie leur handball n'en est
pas là ce qu'il faut que ça aille jusque
là c'est toujours un petit peu un petit
peu difficile
forcément un tel succès ça attire les
foules on a vu les images du du quart de
finale 28 mille spectateurs à nice et un
record historique pour un match de
handball toutes compétitions confondues
pareil pour les gens devant leur télé 4
millions et demi de personnes record
pour d'audience pour la pour la tnt
depuis le lancement de la tnt vous
constatez s'étendent balemagna on va
dire aussi dans les clubs locaux les et
coups de fil les inscriptions
s'enchaînent aussi depuis assure depuis
quelques années quelques mois et puis il
ya encore depuis le mondial en fait à
chaque fois qu'il y a une échéance
importante qui plus est gagné par le
handballeur français il ya les feux
effectivement un effet
sur nombre de nos licenciés et donc
effectivement on est passé là on va au
niveau du département on va perdre son
arrivée à 8800 sied alors que l'umih
licenciés racontez-nous peut-être
historiquement la courbe des chiffres
elle doit être
nous sommes nous avons toujours été en
transactions chacun sauf lorsqu'il n'y a
pas d'échéance olympiques et c'est
vraiment ce ccc peu significatif tout le
temps me licencier 500 milles en france
je crois c'est devenu avec le basket le
deuxième sport collectif le plus
pratiqué en france et que le football
forcément est ce qu'aujourd'hui aussi la
question qui se pose c'est les
structures les équipements sportifs des
communes en france et peut-être sur
saint quentin et dans les yvelines
peuvent accueillir autant de nouveaux
licenciés est ce qu'on a les moyens de
suivre
alors c'est vraiment la grosse
difficulté c'est que je connais quand
même plusieurs clubs sur le département
qui sont des bombes à nous on peut pas
dépasser les plus de 400 licenciés vous
êtes obligés parfois de petits êtres
dire non ou d'un oui il ya des
effectivement des listes d'attentes pour
certains clubs
donc c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
accueillir tout le monde donc c'est
cédera choix donc après il faut trouver
d'autres formes de pratique aussi qu'ils
puissent intéresser les gens vous vous
pensez à quoi quand vous dites bas des
formes de pratiques à quatre contre
quatre
jusqu'ici on est toujours en gymnase
mais peut-être qu'il faut explorer
d'autres salles plus petites pour faire
de plus tôt de l'éducation handball
faire des opérations quatre contre
quatre
par exemple ce qui est en train de se
développer et puis y'a pas forcément que
le handball à cette concept est aussi le
sambal elle s'emballe sur plage voilà
bon là on n'est peut-être pas en termes
développant encore à ça va ça là c'est
des choses qui marchent aussi tout à
fait puis à l'application aussi
fitness aussi qui version handball qui
se développe beaucoup beaucoup aussi
donc non c'est lamballe est en plein
essor
profitons-en tant mieux et souhaitant
que ça dure encore autre atout du
handball et autre point positif pour ce
sport qui ne cesse de se développer
c'est le volley féminin qui est déjà
ultra développé on a une équipe de
france féminine on a 35 % des licenciés
qui sont des femmes j'ai pas forcément
comparé à d'autres sports collectifs
mais les filles sont clairement partie
prenante du sport de cet engouement
en fait ça fait partie aussi des
missions de chacune des instances dont
le comité de développer la pratique
féminine
c'est pour ça que bon là au travers des
derniers chiffres effectivement il ya
une belle progression du pourcentage
féminin mais on n'a pas encore au niveau
de la moyenne nationale
donc c'est pour ça qu'on met en place
des animations sur le département avec
le futur match qui va y avoir au
vélodrome justement j'allais vous en
parlez parfaite parfait lancement pour
ma dernière question sur ce match qui
arrive c'est le 25 mars 25 ans jérôme de
51 matchs de d1 féminine
ici je crois un nom ici parier handball
face à brest bretagne on pourrait battre
record d'un match de d1 féminine c'est
l'objectif
potentiellement 5000 c'est le défi donc
par le fait de voir ce genre d'opération
de battre le record d'affluence qu'il
est de 5000 127 licenciés ces
spectateurs spectateurs je voulais juste
avoir pour terminer avoir un petit avis
vous pensez qu'elle sera le score demain
pour l'équipe de france par une équipe
de france elle est mouillée vous
contrôlez là on a gagné 33 30 contre la
suède france le beignet vous dit combien
dira pas forcément de gros écarts mais
moi je verrais très bien la france gagné
par 2 3 milliards comme commis hier soir
merci voilà merci patrick et chaoui
l'équipe de france vague et on en est
sûr merci patrick chabot pour vos
réponses et on rappelle donc que
l'équipe de france joue affronte la
slovénie jeudi soir et c'est en clair
sur une forcément sur une chaîne
nationale que vous connaissez bien
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
ce soir prochain rendez vous demain
jeudi excellente soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]